miles de personas marchan hacia la plaza
de mayo en esta convocatoria de
organizaciones y partidos de izquierda
en contra de un eventual acuerdo con el
fondo monetario internacional a fines de
enero el presidente alberto fernández
dijo que se había alcanzado un principio
de acuerdo con el organismo para
refinanciar unos 44 mil millones de
dólares de deuda que había tomado el ex
presidente mauricio macri esto es porque
el país tiene serias dificultades para
enfrentar los pagos de esa deuda que se
viene en a lo largo de 2022 y en los
próximos años el presidente alberto
fernández dijo que este era el mejor
acuerdo que se podía lograr pero quienes
están aquí no están de acuerdo dicen que
la deuda es ilegítima que no corresponde
pagar la que no hay que pagarla y que un
acuerdo terminaría llevando un ajuste
del estado que impactaría sobre los
sectores más vulnerables de argentina en
todo caso será el congreso de la nación
el que deba decir si aprueba o no un
eventual acuerdo un congreso donde la
izquierda no tiene los suficientes
números como para vetarlo por sí mismo
pero sí y hay sectores de la coalición
gobernante del frente de todos que se
han mostrado en desacuerdo y no está
claro todavía si lo votarán a favor o en
contra